2019's best new artist dua lipa makin us
proud to that name to that award in 2021
one of the most
nominated artists here at the grammys
this year
do you ever take a step back and just
realize that it's only been two years
since you won best new artist and all
that you have accomplished during that
time
oh thank you so much i know sometimes
when when you say out loud it does
it's like a little bit unbelievable i'm
like a little bit overwhelmed but
i'm so grateful and and you know i feel
like
winning best new artist almost like
pushed me to just like work harder and i
was like all right i gotta prove that i
deserve to be here and
it was just um i've just had such a
blast and so much fun
so i'm i'm so grateful obviously it's
gotta feel really cool to return you
know the first record after that award
and be like oh here i am one of the top
nominees and performing hey hey
i got this it has been an incredibly
difficult year it's been a hard year
it's been a heartbreaking year why do
you think that the entire world
latched on to your record the way that
they did
well the album i guess when i was making
it although i
never envisioned something like this to
happen it did serve for me as like a
form of escapism
i was like trying to shut out anything
that was going on in my life and i just
wanted to have fun
and i feel like when i was
thinking about you know when i was going
to put this album out and whether it was
the right time i was like you know what
the reason why i did this was to get
away from any
outside pressures and i was like maybe
it is the time to put this out and maybe
it can serve
as that for other people and although it
was
probably the scariest decision i'd ever
made yes i had no idea
you know how it'd be received but i'm
just so grateful for the response and
i'm just so happy that
um yeah it it it lives in the world now
so
duo we were working from home and we
were like doing a little move with you
and our sweatpants at the kitchen table
you know and you brought us so much joy
um
tell me about the performance you i
remember seeing you i think it was the
uh mtv awards in europe the yellow and
you had the black and all the yellow
dancers and i was like oh my gosh
this is not just a star this is a
superstar this is an incredible
performance and every
time you have to raise the bar and now
you're back at the grammys so
pressure's on do you feel the pressure
and what do you have planned
um my goodness again i feel like
you know when i say the form like
creating something to get away from like
you know just kind of running away from
like the pressure or the nervousness or
whatever i just want to have
fun and i was like if i'm going to go
i'm just going to go and have fun
and kill it but have fun but um
yeah i'm just i'm just so excited to be
back you know for me
performing's just like it's it's one of
my favorite parts of my job and so to be
able to
be on that stage and put on a
performance i'm just over the moon so
well one of my favorite parts of my job
is watching you arrive on a red carpet
and figuring out what design you're
wearing and what fierce look you're
going to bring so what uh
like what do we have planned for sunday
obviously we're ready of course we're
ready okay
uh i can't tell you well well i'm fine
are you going like angelic like
white ama moment are you going like skin
are you like do you have there's like
a bit of skin a bit of sparkle
a bit she's cute she's cute
okay listen never never disappoints now
i think it's a very cool thing that you
being a
former best new artist winner to have a
current best new artist nominee
who covered your song if you don't want
to see
me dancing with somebody
ingrid andres she covered it have you
heard it
yes okay it's the country yeah the
country version what do you think of the
cover it's cool
yeah i think it's really cool and i just
love that's what i love so much about
music is i feel like
no matter what everything so genre
bending and everyone can just like
it's about like finding having that song
find a home with other people and for
that i'm like the most grateful
it's just the coolest thing to just see
it like shapeshift and take form in
different ways and
with different people it's it's it's
mind-blowing and i love it what does it
mean to you
to be nominated in what i call like the
golden trifecta
like album song um you know like it's a
really top tier and to get the
nominations in that three
those three categories is incredible i
mean it's bonkers really
it's mind-blowing when you found out
would you just like i was
you know it's just it's yeah it does
take you by surprise
and you're just like this is it's
amazing especially being from the uk
it's just like
and kosovo i'm just like what is
happening like i i don't know i i
these things are things that really only
happen in in your dreams so i'm
i feel like well i'm hoping no one's
going to wake me up and be like all
right
time for school or something no you're
amazing we love it congratulations
um congratulations on rehearsal we're so
excited to see you on sunday
julie but the grammys it's going to be
the biggest baddest
best we're going to levitate pun
intended all right awesome